welcome to mom versus chef the cooking
competition were a professional chef and
a mom cook head-to-head preparing the
best dish possible one secret ingredient
our first competitor today is Shahrzad
quiete hi I'm Charlotte Giada I'm a mom
my son is one and a half and his name is
Idris I make youtube videos yeah I have
a blog and a YouTube channel and I host
a couple different shows online I've
been experimenting in the kitchen since
as long as I can remember I'm not a
professional I have no training
whatsoever I feel like my mom taught me
everything I know and everything else I
learned from like blogs and watching
other YouTube videos cooking for a small
child is obviously very different than
cooking for my husband or my friends and
family
winning mom versus chef would be a dream
come true no it would be awesome
bragging rights and I feel like it would
make my mom like really proud I would
give her all the credit in competing
against her is chef nyesha Arrington my
name is chef nyesha Arrington I have a
restaurant called Leona and Venice
California
we offer a cuisine that's called
progressive California cuisine cooking
is one of those things that found me I
grew up with my grandmother and would
cook next to her and at a very young age
I was able to understand what flavor was
you're going into this competition you
know I'm very excited I love love love
kids I hang out with my eight-year-old
nephew all the time and we cook together
and just winning mom versus chef I mean
a lot to him
sharzad chef nyesha today you're going
to be competing to see who can make the
tastiest dish possible featuring one
secret ingredient let me introduce you
to our panel of judges hello my name is
Trent and I'm 10 years old and I like
playing outside with my friends and on
my skateboard hello my name is Nathan
I'm 10 years old and what I like to do
fun
play video games and your last judge is
me my name is Andrew I'm 25 years old
and I like reading outside and by the
way um he is my twin and I am NOT
related to them so I think it's time we
find out what secret ingredient is chefs
whatever you cook today will have to
incorporate this ingredient it will not
be easy
Nathan you want to pull the top off this
thing yes I do Oh
chef's you're cooking with beats today
so like beats by dre this is more like
beats by Nature I've never cooked with
them before and I feel like most kids
hate beats a chef nyesha what do you
think about beat I have cooked with
beats in the past and have certain that
smells like nature they smell really bad
guys you're gonna have 30 minutes to
prepare your dishes your time starts now
okay I think you can sneak a lot of
veggies in a lot of kids foods but beets
I'm gonna try and do something pizza
related so I see that there are some
pitas and I'm thinking that'll be a good
crust hand down hand down I see that
there are jars of pesto and cheese of
course those three things are like
foolproof I'm running to the pantry I'm
looking around I see the sweet potatoes
I see the beets I see yogurt kids like
hash browns I'm gonna make a beet soda
with a sweet potato and beet latke I
take all my ingredients then I just
started putting pesto on the pita and
then I'm getting like little slivers of
beets that I'm just trying to place all
over the little pizza I don't want it to
be tea is that a word I start to form
the mixture for my latke which is
shredded raw beets raw sweet potatoes a
little bit of egg for a binder and I
start to form my patties get those
crisping I want the latke flavors to
marry and really be delicious I'm going
into this trying to like kind of mask
the flavor of the beets I dump a bunch
of cheese on then I pop them in the oven
for
ten ish minutes or so now I'm just sort
of waiting and hoping that it turns out
okay so I'm grading my beats and I know
that I want to sort of squeeze all the
liquid out I know I can use the beet
juice for the soda so I add a little bit
of lemon juice a little bit of honey I'm
going to pour soda water with the beet
juice chefs there's only 15 minutes left
you guys are halfway there uh-huh whoa
that's cool she looks like she's making
like coolin maybe so I make the first
beet cake and I kind of take a piece off
and taste it and it's delicious but I
know I want more texture so I say I'm
gonna use the beet greens and sort of
crisp those up so of course I'm standing
next to chef nyesha and she's doing some
magical sweet potato beet latke and
truly I've never thought beets looked
appetizing until she steps in and I was
like ah I really want to bite let's go
see what the Chester does okay you guys
check on chef nation I'll check on chef
Shores on how's going
pretty good actually what is that this
is a yogurt based sauce with a little
bit of olive oil it's basically going to
counterbalance with the latke
that sounds delicious right thank you
yeah Thank You judges
hello hi Andrew how's everything going
it's going good
this is one of the few times you've ever
cooked those beets is that right this is
the first time ever that I've cooked
beets I tend to like when the when the
secret ingredient is showcased rather
than rather than covered up you're like
that was like a subtle jab oh no no no
no I mean well I'm a mom I don't know a
little try like well good luck I can't
wait to taste your dish yeah thanks only
five minutes left you know I really feel
I have a vision when I go through and
I'm picking my ingredients so I decided
to grab the yogurt and I know I want to
fortify it with like up some flavor and
add some olive oil to it that's gonna go
down on the plate to sort of eat and
round out the latke itself now it's time
to grab my pizzas from the oven they
don't look super fancy they look very
kid-friendly
I'm not nervous because our dishes
couldn't be more different
purrs is like real-deal fancy like mine
is like kid-friendly food I'm very
confident in my dish because I feel that
it offers beats in a new light and I'm
hoping they enjoy it I decide to just
sprinkle a teeny bit of goat cheese on
top of the pizza and that's it I'm
cutting these up can't taste any beats
that makes me happy it's delicious
five four three two one
that's it time's up stop doing what
you're doing
sharzad can you please bring out the
dish yes thank you
it's a pesto pizza I know you guys are
ten-year-old boys I'm gonna go out on a
limb and say that you probably like
pizza I love pizza right okay so yay so
it's just eat a bread with pesto
mozzarella cheese and the beats are
right on top of the pesto under the
cheese and then a tiny little bit of
goat cheese on top of there so dive in
there kiddos let me know what you think
I can really taste the beads which they
don't judge that bad okay good I'm not
sure about the the pesto and the beets
together okay it's like a pizza mix that
nobody would ever come up with the goat
cheese is just a little bit too much
maybe yeah she's not that good I don't
know it did taste very good and I think
you did a great job thank you for your
honest feedback Thank You Fisher's on
here Thank You chef can you describe the
dish for us so what I did was take the
beet and use it in all of its formats I
sort of created the beet raw and mix it
with sweet potato and cook that together
in a cake form on the top is a crispy
beet top chip and then
to a company that you have a beet juice
infused soda that is sweetened with
honey and a touch of lemon juice to kind
of balance out your entire beet
experience do you guys like how it
tastes
I actually don't really like this ring
when you put in the beets it just just
doesn't taste right I think it tastes
good
you definitely get the beet but it's not
full-frontal dirt water like I think
it's it's like very refreshing what's up
he's Anna tastes really good I don't
know why we had to keep it a secret I
don't I don't really like it I don't
think I've ever had the beet leaf before
yeah yeah it's cool this one's gonna be
a tough one Thank You chefs for
everything give us a moment as when you
discuss the winner all right thank you
this is a weird I've never really had
anybody like judge my food before you're
such amazing though I just want to put
that on record and Andrew is all about
that right he like it hails you ride
with my knees like he'd like to be like
it they were good like yeah I'm really
excited and you did a killer job too
let's hug it out are we are we there yet
okay so Shahrzad made the the pesto
pizza with beet did you guys think about
that I just liked everything about the
pizza and I liked how it was like
something that kids like but the goat
cheese is just too much goat cheese I
kind of wish she had done something a
little more with the beat what I did
like about the chef food is that it
actually tasted really good I hate him
drink her main dish I did not really
like I felt like I tasted too much meat
yeah I thought chef Enosh his dish was
really cool because it used a lot of
different parts of the beat I think we
all know who the one
oh yeah let's bring them back in chef
nyesha Shahrzad thank you for coming in
today it was a great competition you
both made some amazing dishes
unfortunately we can only have one
winner tears on your dish was really
tasty but nyesha we thought your dish
was tastier congratulations you're the
winner of this episode of mom versus
chef I'm so excited I won I wish the
little Emmanuel's here next to me
honestly I feel very honored to win this
for him I'm not that upset
chef nyesha's dish looked insane it
looked amazing but you know there can
only be one winner sadly today was not
my day thank you both for coming in you
both made some amazing dishes this has
been mom versus chef oh yes